um let's see we have a bunch of
different people who want to get on
let's go to the nine to zero area code
who's been holding for a now a long time
who's calling from nine to zero today hi
David my name is also David friends call
me rainbow beard um I'm calling today
that can you hear me all right you know
I can hear you extremely well okay
wonderful um I'm calling today with two
things um the first one is I know very
well where I stand on almost all total
political issues both nationally and as
of late more internationally except for
one thing I am very confused on what's
going on and then it's whele okay um I
know it's kind of a lot to ask to do
it'll take a three or four minute phone
call I was hoping maybe you could do in
an upcoming show like a timeline of
Venezuela since the election so I could
figure out what's going on because I
just cannot make heads or tails of it
well I'm gonna try to really bond to you
rainbow I'm gonna try to respond to you
in the most non-political way possible
or the most neutral way because my
audience knows I have a perspective on
this like I'm not a Maduro guy and I am
against US intervention in Venezuela but
I think it would be wrong to blame
American sanctions on Venezuela as
problems on American sanctions given
that those sanctions didn't actually
start until relatively recently but let
me step away for a second from my
personal view the reason why you're
having such a difficult time figuring
out what's going on down there is that
almost all coverage of Venezuela has
been totally propagandized and sometimes
so when games are very clear when
there's a very clear right left versus
right split on an issue it's often much
easier to determine that as a consumer
of media and to parse it in a way that
you can sort of say okay here's why the
right believes this here's why the left
believes this and here's how I have to
sort of interpret it the problem with
Venezuela is that you have some really
crazy stuff happening on the left where
you have a split even within the left
that is fundamentally become one about
is this
all about American imperialism as the
problem is this say capitalism versus
socialism thing and of course the truth
is it's way more complicated than any of
those simplistic explanations so I
understand why you're having trouble
figuring it out because the entire issue
has been totally propagandized including
within the left yeah yeah so okay I'm
not alone then I feel like I'm going out
just because every other issue I know
very well where I stand I'm pretty far
left very strong progressive I was I
mean I was a phone banker for Bernie I
mean I know where I stand in every issue
but this one has just confused the hell
out of me right um so yeah that I guess
that that doesn't really help clear
things up right now it just you I will
likely cover it again and I've just been
waiting to let things sort of settle a
little bit before I do that I appreciate
the real rainbow beard great to hear
from rainbow beard appreciate the call
and on that note we will go to a break
and be right back after this